[Musik]
schönen guten tag wie geht es in schönen
guten tag
sehen sie mal da schon wieder steht
diese mülltonne direkt vor meinem laden
der nachbar helmut stellt sie immer
wieder genau vor meinem fenster und na
ja sie sind doch der vermieter hier
können sie nicht mehr sagen dass das so
nicht geht und dass er rücksicht auf
seine nachbarn nehmen soll
auf mich hat er nicht so schlimm ist das
doch nicht regen sie sich durch nicht
über so auf ich rege mich nicht auf aber
ich brauche kunden um meine miete zu
bezahlen das ist doch auch in ihrem
sinne oder ich spreche mal mit ihm
ich will hier keinen streit unter
nachbarn ich will mich auch nicht mit
ihm streiten aber er sucht den streit
mit mir
er parkt sein auto vor dem laden dazu
parat musik ist unhöflich und jaja
problem haben ich muss noch mit ihnen
über das sprechen aber das hat zeit wir
machen dass ein andermal schön dass sie
wieder da sind frau kurz alles hallo
wer war das mein vermieter herr friese
ich habe mich bei ihm über meinen
nachbarn beschwert er stellt immer sein
müll vor meinen laden
du bist schon sehr deutsch geworden bin
ich nicht